hey everyone it's Mike from orderflows
and in this video I'm going to talk
about uh the importance of orderflow
imbalances you know uh an imbalance is
something that's unique to orderflow
there's a lot of people out there that
say oh they'll look at a bar chart and
say oh there's an imbalance here well
how do you know you're just basically
guessing but when you're looking at an
orderflow footprint chart right you can
actually see it because when you're
looking at um a footprint chart right
it's it's a visualization tool that
combines uh price volume and other
aspects of order flow into a single
chart right a footprint chart allows
traders to see the battle between
aggressive buyers and aggressive sellers
at each price level um against passive
buyers passive Sellers and that's going
to help you determine where there are
imbalances in the market okay and you
know a footprint chart like you see up
here on on my screen is um is is
basically a advanced method of tape
reading right traditional tape reading
has evolved with electronic markets in
the old days you see pictures some guys
um you know in the 1920s standing around
a ticker tape machine modern tape
reading involves analyzing the time and
sales data which shows all executed
trades you know um large trades or a
series of Trades at the ask price or the
bid price can indicate um how strong
aggressive buying or selling is which
leads to uh short-term imbalances okay
and again you know if you're looking at
a normal Candlestick chart honestly you
would just be guessing that there's an
imbalance in the market taking place
right I mean you don't know because you
don't see the volume being transacted at
the bid or the offer and you know how
much volume is there right is it um
normal is it at very light is it very
heavy you don't you don't know that but
if you're looking at a footprint chart
um you know it's very clear it's very uh
very obvious now you know people always
ask me you know what's your favorite uh
tool for analyzing order flow okay and
you know with order flow there there's a
lot of useful tools out there but you
know one of the basic ones which is sort
of one of the the cornerstones of
trading with orderflow is imbalances and
what that is it's you have to think of
the the two-way auction that takes place
in the market right there's a bid and
there's an offer okay and when somebody
buys from the offer they're being an
aggressive buyer someone sells into the
bid they're being an aggressive seller
and it's this relationship in the 2-way
auction that you're going to be able to
see imbalances so for example example um
you know in this green candle right here
in the middle you see three against 24
three lots were sold into the bid 24
were bought from the
offer what we have here is a buying
imbalance right because um there's 24
bought from the offer only three sold
into the bid it's greater than a
predetermined ratio I use 4:1 most
Traders use 4:1 some still use uh 3:1
others use you know higher
number but the important thing is that
what you have is an imbalance um you see
on the next price level 13 against 19
there's no blue or red numbers because
this is just the normal trade that's
taking place 13 were sold into the bid
19 were bought from the offer now a
selling balance is the
opposite here you have 32 against four
so four were bought from the offer 32
were sold into the bid okay so obviously
32 is greater than 4:1 versus 4 okay
just say down here 13 against two okay
the 13 that was sold is is greater than
400% or 4 to1 all right and generally
speaking in green up candles you're
going to have buying imbalances in red
Down Candles you're going to have um
selling imbalances now there are going
to be times where like you're going to
have a candle like this red candle where
you have selling imbalances as well as a
a buying imbalance okay or you know if
there's a green one here where you have
a buying imbalance as well as a selling
imbalance okay and they have different
meanings right I'm not going to get into
that cuz really want to talk about you
know I made a video the other day
talking about stacked imbalances okay
and you know stacked imbalances are very
visual for an orderful Trader because
you're looking at you know three
consecutive price levels with three
consecutive buying imbalances or in the
case of a stack selling a balance three
or more consecutive levels of selling a
balance a stack ly on top of each other
and it's it's something that's very easy
to see in the footprint
chart but there are going to be times
where you have bars that have say three
or more buying imbalances but they're
not stacked neatly on top of each other
one here is 27 then you got normal 5
versus 8 in the order flow then you got
42 versus 5 then you got 28 versus 55 so
you got a buying and balance regular
order flow buying and balance regular
order flow buying and balance now does
that mean that just because they're not
stacked neatly on top of each other
they're not important of course not
they're still important okay and you
know in in the old days you'd have to be
locked and loaded onto your chart to to
see these taking place right to
understand its importance um you know I
created my own orderflow footprint chart
the orderflow is Trader the link is
below in the description if you're
interested in it where we make it very
easy to see bars that have multiple
imbalances okay now before I show you
people going to say so what why do I
need to see that well you know sometimes
there's going to be of buying that's
spread
out within the bar you know or or within
a certain time period you know again you
know generally when you have a stack
buying a balance or stack selling a
balance there a big burst immediately
maybe a big order going through the
market okay that's important but what if
you have sort of sustained buying going
on over 15 seconds right does that mean
it's it's not as important as a big
burst that takes place in in one shot no
of course not it's still aggressive
buying that's taking place it's just
this time it's being massaged into the
market right everyone always likes to
talk about Market manipulation but
really what Market you know don't don't
get caught up in this whole um thing of
you know oh the markets are manipulated
you know the alos are out doing this and
that really
what um you know these multiple
imbalances where they're spread out in a
bar really what's taking place is the
execution algo is trying to sort of hide
the
intention of what the big Traders is
trying to do rather than just bursting
it all out in one shot it's splitting it
up and if you've ever spent any time
with execution alos you know um you know
reading up on them from you know what
the big banks give out to their trading
customers you know that they they have
time slicer things like that where take
a big order and it's going to slice it
into um smaller
pieces or you know a big order it's
going to execute it over instead of 1
second you know like just buy 100 it'll
buy 100 but it'll split it up you know
every few seconds sort of give you know
a little bit in a little bit in a little
bit in give the market some time to sort
of come back in and fill in the bids and
the offers all right
so when um I created my order flow
Trader you know I I obviously I
recognize the importance of bars that
have multiple imbalances you know three
or more imbalances but they're just
spread out in the bar okay and let's
just enable it here it's under volume
imbalance enable multiple imbalances and
I'll just show you here what it's going
to do is going to draw a box around the
bar okay so you can see
here this Bar's got um it's got stack
buying and balance same with this Bar's
got a stacked buying and balance it's
showing up because obviously it's three
or more buying and balances in the bar
even this one's got two more uh three
more here so if there's a stack buying
balance it'll still draw the Box run cuz
it does meet up but look at this bar
here um 117
4227 okay this was a bar I after a
number then the next bar right
afterwards you got buying balances
spread out 1 two three
right in the bar immediately after the
bar after you know the 730 number so
it's telling you there's aggressive
buying taking place and you might not
notice it if you're just looking at a
bar chart um where is this is that bar
right here this green candle let me just
make this chart a bit bigger
here all right this is it you might not
notice it that there's a lot of
aggressive buying because this candle is
kind of n the script right it's got big
Wicks on both sides and it's got you
know kind of a small body but if you
watching you know the imbalances taking
place you know it got one two three here
okay for this nice little rally and
people say well you know what good is
this right because I I could already see
the stack buying and balances do I
really need to see that well take a look
at this okay so we're going up right
multiple bars with multiple buying and
balances spread out inside and then we
get this bar right
here 1 two 1 two so it's got four
selling AB balances in it now they're
not stacked neatly on top of each other
it's coming in this area where the
market is going
sideways okay so you know again it
doesn't look like anything super special
all right it's just a market that's
going sideways but then what happens
boom and then it's really drops I mean
it drops from uh what is that
6870 six area all the way down to you
know below uh 50 here and again if if
you're looking at here right this is
this is your Candlestick chart here okay
this area right in here right I mean let
me uh highlight this here what do I
highlight it with
um I'll just put this ellipse around it
here Circle right this red
bar is this really telling you anything
super
bearish taking place in here
no I mean this is a market that's
basically going sideways here okay right
in
here but if you know if you're looking
at the order
flow you know you got a bunch of
imbalances taking place you're just not
stacked neatly on top of each other all
right and and that's important
now you know another that's by using an
orderflow footprint chart okay that
makes it uh very easy to see now again I
I realize some people don't like to use
a footprint chart they like to use their
uh Candlestick charts which is fine um
we do have a tool for those users called
the toolbx actually um let's just pull
it up
here okay and it's going to be
under volume balance okay so it's going
to show
me the
bars that
have three or more imbalances is in them
right here again you wouldn't notice
that if you're looking at a
normal Candlestick chart okay you can
see here on the way up it's coming in on
the way down it's coming in right here
right this is the the beauty of using
order flow right
and really what you want to do when
you're trading right is you know
everyone says a small follow the smart
money follow the big Traders well how
how can you see what the big tra are
doing if you're looking at a normal
footprint chart honestly you can't you
got to be looking here you got be
analyzing the actual volume so if you're
really interested in in following the
smart
money right the the big the big trades
that are taking place you you need to be
looking at basically a footprint chart
to see what's where these bigger players
are being
active okay and you know just you know a
quick side
note imbalances
either multiple imbalances or stacked
imbalances now I really like to look at
bars that have three or more buying IM
balances three or more selling balances
whether they're stacked or spread out um
you know I I treat them the same I put
the same importance on them you know if
it's a bar that's just got one buying a
balance or one selling a balance I don't
usually put uh too much weight in it
because it could just be a big order
that hit the market okay know someone's
got 50 lots to sell I mean that's that's
normal okay
and what
what imbalances often do is they often
precede significant price moves okay so
if there's any information that you can
get from your
chart that's going to tell you that you
know over and over and over generally
when this happens a move a big move
happens that's information you want to
be taking advantage of and that's why I
I love using orderflow that's why I
think um you know a footprint chart is
is is the best way to analyze the market
you know people will throw stones at me
oh you know orderflow is a scam it's not
you know order you read the history
books or not history books you read the
the
books on trading you know if you've ever
read Market Wizards a lot of those
Traders talk about reminiscence of a
stock operator the guy was a tape reader
all right he was looking at the volume
so all these people say w you know order
flow is just a fat it's not you know
it's been around for well over 100 years
actually it's been around a lot longer
than that and it's just very useful tool
okay and again you know if you're not
looking at the volume you can't just by
by looking at a simple bar chart
determine where there's aggressive
buying where there's aggressive selling
okay you just can't you know I know some
people like to say well there's a big
red bar here you got an imbalance
right okay I yeah I got a big red down
candle
it came
back how do I know that's an imbalance
you know how do you really know what's
taking place in a bar unless you're
looking at how the volume transact all
right everybody I'm going to end this
one for there you know in my next video
I want to talk about something that's uh
deals with imbalances but it's it's a
different way to look at imbalances you
know we tend to look at imbalances over
a bar but um you know in my next video
I'm going to show you guys a little
trick on how to uh sort of maximize some
uh the imbalances over time all right so
thanks and I'll see you guys on the next
video